Jug Burkett is a businessman in Dallas, a Vietnam vet. And about 10 years ago, he was in charge of a campaign that was trying to build a memorial to honor Vietnam vets from Texas. It wasn't easy.
Jug Burkett是一位达拉斯的商人，也是一名越战老兵。大约10年前，他负责发起了一场运动，旨在为德克萨斯州的越战老兵建立一座纪念碑。这并不容易。
The immediate public reaction was, why should we give money for those bums?
当时公众的第一反应是：我们为什么要给那些流浪汉捐钱？
So Mr. Burkett started doing research so he could prove to people that most Vietnam vets are not bums. They have jobs. They didn't go crazy in the war. They're leading utterly normal lives.
于是伯克特先生开始进行研究，以便向人们证明大多数越战老兵并非流浪汉。他们有工作，他们在战争中没有发疯，他们过着完全正常的生活。
Then, right in the middle of doing that, there was a murder here in Dallas. A vagrant killed a policeman at a traffic stop. And the headlines basically said, Vietnam veteran goes berserk. And for a week, there were follow-up stories about how Vietnam made him do it.
就在他进行这项工作时，达拉斯发生了一起谋杀案。一名流浪汉在交通拦截检查时杀害了一名警察。头条新闻基本上都说：“越战老兵发狂了”。在接下来的一周里，后续报道都在宣扬越战是如何导致他做出这种行为的。
You were in the situation where this was going to hurt your fundraising efforts.
你当时处于一种局面，这对你的筹款工作很不利。
Well, it was hurting my fundraising. Every time a bad story like that appeared, I would get heckled by the people that I was trying to get money out of. Hey Burkett, I saw another one of your boys went crazy last night, kind of thing.
是的，这损害了我的筹款。每当这样的负面新闻出现，我试图筹款的对象就会嘲笑我。他们会说：“嘿，伯克特，我昨晚又看到一个你们那伙人发疯了”之类的话。
Mr. Burkett is not the kind of man who sits by and idly watches things go to hell. He took action.
伯克特先生不是那种袖手旁观、任由事情变糟的人。他采取了行动。
Anyway, I checked this particular fellow's individual military record, and it turned out he never served in Vietnam. He'd only been in the Navy three months and he got kicked out on a psychological charge.
总之，我查了这个人的个人服役记录，结果发现他从未在越南服役。他在海军只待了三个月，就因心理问题被开除了。
We live in a world full of people faking this thing and that. And it turns out that spotting a fake Vietnam vet is one of the easier lies to get to the bottom of. Mr. Burkett started routinely checking the bona fides of anybody in the news who claimed to have served in the war. He claims that he's found hundreds of fakers. He discovered some famous people fibbing about their service records to buff up their public images, like actor Brian Dennehy. He found defendants in murder cases claiming to be war heroes hoping to beat the rap, or alternately, claiming that war made them crazy and they can't be held responsible. He found big public events misreported.
我们生活在一个充满了虚假行径的世界里。事实证明，识别假冒的越战老兵是揭穿谎言最简单的方法之一。伯克特先生开始定期核实新闻中任何自称参加过那场战争的人的真实身份。他声称自己发现了数百名造假者。他发现了一些名人为了美化公众形象而编造服役记录，比如演员布莱恩·丹内利（Brian Dennehy）。他还发现谋杀案的被告自称是战争英雄，希望以此逃脱制裁，或者反过来，声称战争让他们发疯，因此他们不应承担责任。他还发现了大型公共活动中存在的虚假报道。
Do you remember the killing up in Edmond, Oklahoma? It was one of the first mass killings in the post office. 14 postal workers killed. Well again, Vietnam veteran goes berserk story. I checked the man's military record. He never served in Vietnam.
你还记得俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙的那起杀戮事件吗？那是邮局发生的第一批大规模杀戮事件之一，有14名邮政工作人员被杀。当时又是“越战老兵发狂”的报道。我查了这个人的服役记录，他从未在越南服役。
And often, what's amazing about these cases is the outrageousness of the lies. VA officials and career officers who fabricated and exaggerated among people who could easily catch them out. A soldier who is quoted extensively in the book, We Were Soldiers Once... and Young , a history of the battle of Vietnam's Ia Drang Valley.
这些案例中最令人震惊的往往是谎言的离谱程度。退伍军人事务部的官员和职业军官在容易识破他们的人面前进行捏造和夸大。有一名士兵在《我们曾是战士》一书中被大量引用，那本书记录了越战中德浪河谷战役的历史。
There's a man in there named Kreischer who is right in the middle of the battle. And of course, that thing is an oral history type thing. It skips around. And they're talking about being on the tree line and all this thing. And Kreischer after the war actually founded their alumni group, started that. He then became a big fixture in the 1st Cav Division organization, ultimately became its president.
书中有一个叫克雷舍（Kreischer）的人，他正处于战斗的中心。当然，那本书属于口述历史类型，内容跳跃。他们谈论着在树线作战之类的经历。战后，克雷舍实际上成立了他们的校友会，他是发起人。后来他在第一骑兵师的组织中成了重要人物，最终担任了主席。
And somebody gave me a tip that this may not all quite be on the up and up. And I got his military record. The guy had been discharged four months before that battle. He wasn't in the battle and yet had convinced everybody who was in the battle that he was with them shoulder to shoulder. He convinced the people in the same squad, the same platoon. He convinced the company commanders. And not only did he convince them, they all elected him their president.
有人提醒我，这一切可能并非完全属实。我拿到了他的服役记录。那家伙在那场战斗发生前四个月就已经退伍了。他根本没参加过战斗，却让所有参加过战斗的人都相信他曾与他们并肩作战。他让同一个小队、同一个排的人都相信了，他让连长们也相信了。不仅如此，他们还一致推选他为主席。
That's because the person who has to convince people that he is the real thing is going to do a much more aggressive job of being the real thing than the person who actually is the real thing.
这是因为，那个必须说服别人自己是“正牌货”的人，比起真正的“正牌货”，会表现得更加卖力。
You are going to know more about that battle than the people that were there. You're going to consume everything written about it. You're going to send off for things. You're going to watch the documentaries. The guy who was there-- this was an episode that flashed by, and he went on to the next thing.
你会比那些亲历者更了解那场战斗。你会消化关于它的一切文字。你会到处搜寻相关资料。你会观看纪录片。而真正亲历过的人——这只是他们生命中一闪而过的插曲，然后他们就继续过自己的生活了。
Well, today on our program, The Real Thing, stories of people drawn to some idea, some picture, some thing that they just want to be. Some people doing it innocently, some less innocently, and how easy it is to slip from one to the other. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
今天节目主题是《真东西》，讲述人们被某种想法、某种形象、某种事物所吸引，而一心想要成为它们的故事。有些人是无心之举，有些则不那么单纯，而且从中滑向另一方是多么容易。来自WBEZ芝加哥和公共广播国际，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Act One of our program today, My Life With the Thrill Kill Cult, in which a woman, as part of her job, starts hanging around with some gang members and slowly finds herself changing the way she dresses, changing the way she talks, changing her cigarette brand to theirs. Act Two, Black Like Me, a story of hockey and basketball and what it means to be really black. Act Three, Drawl, what's it mean to talk like a real southerner, and why one multimillion dollar industry can't seem to figure it out. Act Four, Real Love, an illustration from Sandra Loh of the rule that if it seems too good to be true, well, maybe it isn't. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕是《我与惊悚杀戮邪教的生活》，一位女性因为工作关系开始与帮派成员混在一起，慢慢发现自己改变了穿着方式、谈话方式，甚至连抽的烟都换成了他们的牌子。第二幕是《黑如我》，一个关于曲棍球、篮球以及什么是真正黑人的故事。第三幕是《腔调》，探讨说出地道的南方口音意味着什么，以及为什么一个价值数百万美元的行业似乎总是搞不懂它。第四幕是《真爱》，桑德拉·洛（Sandra Loh）用一个例子说明了“如果事情好得令人难以置信，那么它可能就是假的”这一规律。请继续收听。
Act One. Act One of our show today is the story of somebody who tried to get closer to the real thing and tried, and why in the end it did not go too well. Kelly McEvers was a newspaper writer here in Chicago and started to get interested in stories that she was hearing about girl gang members. Now, she was somebody who did not know much about the gang world. But she got an assignment and tried to get closer to the real thing.
第一幕。今天节目的第一幕讲述了一个试图接近“真东西”却最终失败的故事。凯莉·麦克埃弗斯（Kelly McEvers）曾是芝加哥的一名报社记者，她开始对听到的关于女孩帮派成员的故事产生兴趣。她原本对帮派世界知之甚少，但她接到了一项任务，试图去接近“真东西”。
I bought a $50 car. It was a beat-up 1983 Dodge Shadow. And I started just sort of riding around the neighborhood. I'd had a couple social workers through friends who'd said, if you stop by this one corner and ask for so-and-so, maybe he'll help you meet so-and-so. So that's how I did it. I'd go in the afternoons in my $50 car and just sort of drive around and ask for people. And my first good connection was two twins, a set of twins, over in the Humboldt Park area. I drove up in my car and they thought I was a custy.
我花50美元买了一辆破破烂烂的1983年款道奇Shadow。我就开始在街区里转悠。通过朋友介绍，我认识了几位社会工作者，他们告诉我，如果你去街角找某某人，或许他能帮你联系到谁。于是我就这么做了。我下午开着那辆50美元的车，在街上到处转，打听人。我的第一个有效线索是在洪堡公园区的一对双胞胎。我开车过去，他们把我当成了“买家”（custy）。
A custy meaning?
“买家”是指什么？
Meaning someone who wants to purchase drugs. Custy, short for customer, I guess. So they came running up to my car. And they're like, you straight? You straight? What you need? What you want? And I was like, well, that's not really what I'm doing here. I'm a friend of so-and-so's and I'm a reporter and I want to know about girls. And they said, oh, you want to know about girls? And they jumped in my car and we went riding around. And that's how it got started.
指想买毒品的人。“Custy”是“customer”（顾客）的缩写，我想。所以他们跑到我的车前问：“你带货了吗？你带货了吗？你需要什么？你想要什么？”我说，其实我不是来干这个的。我是某某的朋友，我是个记者，我想了解一下女孩们的情况。他们说，噢，你想了解女孩？于是他们跳上我的车，我们一起到处兜风。一切就是这样开始的。
And so at first when you were hanging around with them, you kept a little glossary for yourself?
所以起初你和他们混在一起时，还为自己准备了一份词汇表？
Yeah. It was pretty academic. I tried to write down all of the strange words that they said that I didn't understand, and then, of course, use them in a sentence as well.
是的。这相当学术。我努力记下所有他们说的我听不懂的奇怪词汇，当然，还要尝试把它们用在句子中。
Wow. How very 11th grade of you.
哇，你还挺像个11年级学生的。
I know.
我知道。
What would you do when you would just hang out with them?
你和他们混在一起时都会干什么？
Hanging out is a lot of driving around and seeing who's where and who's doing what with whom, and then going to the next spot and gossiping about what you saw at the last spot. They're 17 years old. There's really not that much going on. They don't go to school. They don't work. There's just not a lot to talk about except each other. And there was always someone fighting with someone. There was always some sort of drama going on. At any given time in the day, some girl was mad at somebody else. And it was more that it was different than anything I'd ever known than it being really this criminally exciting experience that I thought it was going to be.
混在一起就是开车到处逛，看看谁在哪儿，谁在跟谁干什么，然后去下一个地方，八卦刚才看到的趣事。他们才17岁，其实也没什么特别的事可做。他们不去上学，也不工作。除了彼此之外，没太多可聊的。而且总有人在吵架，总会有各种各样的闹剧发生。在一天里的任何时候，总有某个女孩在对某人生气。与其说这是一次真正惊险刺激的犯罪经历，不如说它只是和我以前所知的一切都不同而已。
Well, it sounds like the excitement was simply the excitement of being in high school, even though they weren't in high school. But basically, it was the excitement of being 17.
听起来那种刺激感纯粹就是高中生的那种兴奋，尽管他们根本没在读高中。但归根结底，就是17岁特有的兴奋感。
Slowly-- and I don't know when this started to happen, because I really wasn't conscious of it. The only reason I know it happened is because my friends tell me now. I started to dress a little bit differently. I started wearing lots of sports T-shirts and jeans and sweatpants and platform shoes, and pulling my hair back, and wearing darker lipstick, and just starting to fit in-- trying to fit in-- all for the sake of the story of course, in my mind at the time.
慢慢地——我不知道这是什么时候开始的，因为我真的没有意识到。我之所以知道是因为我的朋友们现在告诉了我。我开始穿得有点不同了。我开始穿很多运动T恤、牛仔裤、运动裤和厚底鞋，把头发扎在脑后，涂上更深色的唇膏，开始融入他们——努力融入——当然，在我当时看来，这都是为了写报道的缘故。
How were you talking?
你说话的方式呢？
Just a little bit with an edge. "Hey, Kelly. Whassup? How you doin' Pista? Oh, what's goin' on?" You know, just a little bit. Maybe that sounds like a lot. But if you're standing around with a group of people, you want to sort of fit in. A little bit of that, a little bit of "damn," you know. "Oh, look at him. He's fine." You know, maybe not "foyne." I wouldn't say it like that. But just a little, "fine." You know, something. And definitely sort of a little more head movement and gesturing that I wouldn't do before.
带上了一点痞气。“嘿，凯莉。咋了？你好吗Pista？噢，怎么回事？”你知道，就是一点点。也许听起来很多。但如果你和一群人站在一块儿，你会想融入他们。带一点那种腔调，再带一点“该死”之类的词。你知道，“噢，快看他。他真帅。”你知道，也许不是“foyne”那样说。但我会稍微说一点“帅”（fine）。带上一点点头动作和手势，这是我以前不会做的。
At one point, you took them to this restaurant Leo's?
有一次，你带他们去了那家叫Leo's的餐厅？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, this is this sort of hipster restaurant here in Chicago. And so what happens?
好的，这在芝加哥算是一家潮店。然后发生了什么？
I'm sort of doing an interview with them. But it just turns into very funny conversation. They're very loud and opinionated. And at one point, a young woman who looks like a rock star says to Linda, this girl that I'm interviewing, "Is anyone using that chair?"
我当时正在采访他们，但这却变成了一场非常有趣的对话。他们非常吵闹，很有主见。当时，一个看起来像摇滚明星的年轻女子对琳达——我采访的那个女孩说：“这把椅子有人坐吗？”
And she's like, "Yeah, my foot." And she's just kidding really. But this girl's very upset and sort of offended. And she's like, "No, no, no, you can have my chair. I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding, honey."
她说：“有，我脚在坐。”她其实只是开玩笑。但那女孩非常生气，觉得被冒犯了。她又说：“没没没，你可以坐，我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的亲爱的。”
And she's like, "Yeah, whatever. It's OK," or something. Like, "I don't need your chair anyway." And it was so funny to me. Because I got to be on their side of it. I was with them as they were fighting with someone who normally would be me, I guess.
那女的就说：“是啊，随便啦，没关系。”或者类似的话，“反正我也不需要你的椅子。”我觉得这太搞笑了。因为我竟然站到了他们这一边。我和他们在一起，看他们与原本应该是“我这类人”的人争吵。
So how far did it go?
事情发展到什么程度了？
I was working with a photographer. And she had just come on as a photographer from another city and was really trying to make a good impression and was trying to be very professional about the whole thing. And I feel so bad because I think I sucked her into this whole thing. And so one night we were driving around with a bunch of people on our way to the beach. And we had two carloads of people and she was driving.
当时我正和一个摄影师合作。她刚从另一个城市调过来，非常想给人留下好印象，努力保持职业。我感到非常内疚，因为我觉得是我把她拉进了整个乱局。那天晚上，我们要去海滩，车里挤满了人。我们两辆车在行驶，她在开车。
And all of a sudden, the other car full of mostly gang guys-- we were with some gang guys too-- started racing us. They took off from the light and started to fool around. We were going down Fullerton Avenue, a very busy street, going eastbound toward the lake. And so the guys in our car were like, "Come on, Heather. Come on, you can do it. Just bust through these lights."
突然，后面那辆大多是帮派成员的车——我们当时也和一些帮派分子在一起——开始跟我们飙车。他们从红灯处冲了出去，开始瞎闹。我们行驶在富勒顿大道（Fullerton Avenue）上，那是一条非常繁忙的大街，向东驶往湖边。我们车里的家伙们就开始起哄：“加油，希瑟（Heather）。加油，你能行的。直接闯过这些红灯。”
And she's like, "No. I can't do that. No. I can't do that."
她说：“不行。我不能那样做。不行。我做不到。”
So I'm behind her going, "Come on, Heather. Come on. We really got to do this. I mean, they'll really think we're cool." That wasn't what I was saying, but that was what I was thinking. Like, you've got to do this, Heather. You have to do it. And she didn't want to do it. And she did.
所以我坐在后面说：“加油，希瑟。加油。我们真的得这么做。我是说，他们会觉得我们真的很酷。”我嘴上没说，但心里就是这么想的。就像是，你必须这么做，希瑟。你一定要做。她不想做，但她最后还是做了。
She did? She ran the lights?
她真的做了？她闯了红灯？
She ran the lights.
她闯了红灯。
She drag raced up Fullerton Avenue?
她在富勒顿大道上飙车？
She drove 75 miles an hour on Fullerton Avenue. And she won.
她在富勒顿大道上开到了时速75英里。而且她赢了。
And so were you right? Did they respect you after that?
那你猜对了吗？之后他们尊重你了吗？
I don't think they respected us. For the night, yes. Did it last throughout these months where I thought I was going to get this great story? Probably not. That night, yeah.
我不认为他们尊重了我们。那天晚上也许是吧。但这在那几个月里持续了吗？我原本以为自己能写出一篇伟大的报道。大概没有。那天晚上，是的。
"Oh Heather, you're so cool." We got back to the neighborhood. She was very popular that night. "You shoulda seen her go. We didn't think a white chick could do that, but--" You know, that sort of thing.
“噢希瑟，你太酷了。”我们回到街区。她那天晚上非常受欢迎。“你应该看她开车的样子。我们没想到一个白人妞能做到那样，但是……”你知道，就是那一套。
Did it occur to you at any point during that-- I have crossed a line?
在那过程中，你有没有意识到：我已经越界了？
No. Not then. There was a point, and I don't know when it was, that I just sort of stopped taking notes, stopped interviewing people, and just started living with them and not being someone who was documenting them.
没有。当时没有。有那么一刻，我不知道是什么时候，我开始不再记笔记，不再采访人，只是开始和他们生活在一起，不再是作为一个记录者。
And when you think about it, what happened?
当你回想的时候，发生了什么？
I guess I just thought everything was becoming a means to an end, that the more time I spent with them, I would eventually have that one experience that then I would take notes. I think that's how I explained it to myself.
我想我只是认为一切都变成了达到目的的手段，觉得我在一起的时间越长，最终就会有那么一次经历，然后我会去记笔记。我想我是这样说服自己的。
You kept expecting that there might be some other deeper gang experience than the one you were having?
你一直期待着会有比你当时所经历的更深刻的帮派体验？
Right.
没错。
It's interesting, because in a way what you're saying is that you expected that this just sort of hanging around-- well, this isn't the real gang life. The real gang life is still those fights and shootings which are about to happen. So you were expecting that at some point, I'm going to be so inside, they're going to take me to that, not realizing that the actual gang life is actually just hanging around on the street gossiping about who is whose girlfriend.
很有意思，因为从某种意义上说，你以为那种“瞎混”——好吧，这不是真正的帮派生活。真正的帮派生活仍然是那些即将发生的打斗和枪击。所以你期待着在某个时刻，我能如此深入，他们会带我去经历那些，却没意识到真实的帮派生活其实就是在大街上游荡，八卦谁是谁的女朋友。
And selling drugs. And fighting about who should have the drugs and who owes who $10 and who slept with whose boyfriend.
还有卖毒品。争论谁该拿毒品，谁欠了谁10块钱，谁和谁的男朋友睡了。
Before you got into this situation, what did you think the appeal of that life would be, gang life?
在你陷入这种境地之前，你认为帮派生活吸引人的地方会是什么？
I thought it would be, like I said, much more criminal. I thought I would see big gang fights. Not like the Jets or anything in West Side Story , but I really thought that I would see groups of people fighting each other. And I've heard numerous stories about these types of fights. But I never saw them. So even from my initial interviews, the stories that I was hearing about what was going on in these neighborhoods, I thought I would see that. I never saw anyone get hurt. I saw a drive-by shooting blocks away, a car driving by and shooting at someone. They weren't hurt. I'm saying this like I'm disappointed. I didn't see this overly criminal life that I thought I was going to see.
我以为会更犯罪一些，比如我会看到大型帮派火拼。不像《西区故事》里的喷气机帮（Jets）那种，但我真的以为会看到一群人互相殴打。我听说过无数关于这类火拼的故事，但我从未亲眼见过。所以即使从我最初的采访中，我听到的那些关于街区发生的事情，我以为我能见到。我从未见过有人受伤。我曾在几个街区外见过一次车内枪击，一辆车经过并向某人开枪。他们没受伤。我说得好像我感到失望似的，我没看到我以为会有的那种过度犯罪的生活。
And is that because it wasn't actually going on?
那是因为它实际上并没有发生吗？
Well, yes. At least in this particular gang, it's about business. It's about making money and selling drugs.
嗯，是的。至少在这个特定的帮派里，这是生意。是关于赚钱和贩毒。
But selling drugs is a criminal activity. And seeing them sell drugs is witnessing a criminal business.
但贩毒本身就是犯罪活动。看到他们贩毒就是在见证一个犯罪生意。
That's true. Mm-hmm. I guess I became as blase about it as everyone else in the neighborhood.
没错。嗯，我想我已经变得和街区里其他人一样对它感到麻木了。
Did you worry at any point that you were fetishizing, that it's easy to fetishize what these lives were like?
你有没有担心过自己在将其“恋物化”，因为人们很容易将这种生活神圣化或美化？
Yeah. Yeah, definitely.
是的。是的，绝对有。
Tell me about that.
跟我说说这个。
Yeah. It made really great anecdotes. And people thought it was very funny. I mean, it is funny. But it's also very serious, what their lives are like. Even though they just sort of hang out and sell a couple drugs here and there, they still know what it's like to find your boyfriend dead in a car. Death is always sort of present.
是的。它确实成了非常棒的轶事。人们觉得这很有趣。我是说，这确实有趣。但他们的生活状况也非常严峻。尽管他们只是混混日子，偶尔卖点毒品，他们依然知道发现自己的男朋友死在车里是什么滋味。死亡在某种程度上一直都在。
Is it your impression that the fantasy is spinning through their heads as well?
你觉得这种幻想也在他们脑海中萦绕吗？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对。
How do they see it?
他们是怎么看待它的？
I believed their perception of themselves. They see it as very-- the life, the world. You have to live the life to know the life, this very, very hard place to be. Yet they wouldn't be anywhere else.
我相信他们对自己的认知。他们认为生活，这个世界，非常……你必须“活过这种生活”才能了解它，这是一个非常、非常艰难的地方。然而，他们哪儿也不会去。
In their minds, is it this glamorous, criminal, outsider life?
在他们心中，这是一种迷人、充满犯罪气息、局外人的生活吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
噢，是的。没错。
But is the life that you're leading the life that you're actually leading or the life that you tell yourself you're leading?
但你所过的生活，是你真正过的生活，还是你告诉自己你正在过的生活？
For me at the time, it was the one I was telling myself I was leading.
对我当时而言，那是我告诉自己我正在过的生活。
Well, and for them.
嗯，对他们来说也是。
Yeah.
是的。
But I mean, I think it's easy to make that sound sort of silly. But I have to say, there are a lot of people who are going through life with a little movie in their head that's different than what's actually happening.
但我认为，让这听起来有点傻很容易。但我必须说，有很多人的生活中都有一个小电影，与实际发生的事情不同。
So maybe I shouldn't be so upset about doing this. I thought, and still do think, that I had the greatest job in the world when I did this story. If I can do this, if I can hang out, if I can become somebody else for a summer, that's a great job.
所以也许我不应该对自己做这件事感到难过。我曾认为，现在也依然认为，当我做这个报道时，我拥有世界上最棒的工作。如果我能做到这一点，如果我能去混，如果我能在那个夏天变成另一个人，那是一份伟大的工作。
Kelly McEvers.
凯莉·麦克埃弗斯。
[MUSIC- "I AM A CLICHE" BY X-RAY SPEX]
[音乐- 《我是老套》 X-Ray Spex乐队]
Act Two, Black Like Me. Well, our program today is about what happens when you try to turn yourself into the real thing, some notion of the real thing, an idea which is always a kind of fiction, a kind of cliche. Glenn Loury is a professor at Boston University. He's written a fair amount about black people trying to define what it is to be a real black person. He does not like the idea of cultural uniformity. I remember him once actually defending the notion that if a black person likes Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young, then that is still a black thing to do, because a black person is doing it. He rejects a kind of rigid cultural conformity, as I say. But recently he had this experience with his son.
第二幕，《黑如我》。我们的节目今天探讨的是当你试图把自己变成“真东西”时会发生什么，某些对“真东西”的观念，一种永远是某种虚构、某种陈词滥调的想法。格伦·洛里（Glenn Loury）是波士顿大学的一位教授。他写过不少关于黑人试图定义什么是“真正的黑人”的文章。他不喜欢文化统一性的观点。我记得他曾公开捍卫这一观点：如果一个黑人喜欢Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young乐队，那依然是一件“黑人的事”，因为这是一个黑人在做。他拒绝那种僵化的文化从众。但最近，他和他的儿子有了这样的经历。
Oh, this was in South Suburban Boston. We were walking in one of the forest preserves around here-- a Sunday, mid-afternoon, it was in the winter time-- just to get out and find something to do. So we'd driven into the forest and parked and were just walking along. And yeah, we stumbled on this frozen lake. And there were guys out there playing hockey.
噢，那是在波士顿南郊。那是一个冬天的周日午后，我们正在那附近的森林保护区散步——只是想出来找点事做。我们开车进入森林，停好车，顺着路走。然后，是的，我们偶然发现了一个结冰的湖，有几个家伙在上面打冰球。
And my son, who at the time was probably three or four years old, was really interested in what was going on and started squealing and straining to get away from me. He would have run out on the ice and joined them if I'd have let him. And all I could think about was, all of these guys are white. They were all New England guys who liked to play hockey. And I didn't want my son out there doing that. I wanted him to play basketball or something respectable.
我儿子当时大概三四岁，对场面非常感兴趣，开始尖叫并挣扎着想离开我。如果我允许的话，他早就跑上冰面加入他们了。我脑子里能想到的只有：这些家伙全是白人。他们都是喜欢打冰球的新英格兰小伙子。我不想让我儿子去干那个。我希望他去打篮球，或者做点体面的事。
Some of those things die hard. And even when I had this intellectual position rejecting that kind of imposition of cultural uniformity in the name of blackness, still, when it came down to my kid and what his enthusiasms would be, I had rather hoped they'd be closer to something that I could recognize from my growing up on the South Side of Chicago. Sadly, my kid is growing up on the South Side of Boston.
有些观念是根深蒂固的。即使我在智识上拒绝那种以“黑人性”为名的文化统一性强加，当涉及到我的孩子和他会产生什么热情时，我还是希望它们能更接近我在芝加哥南区成长过程中所熟悉的东西。遗憾的是，我的孩子正在波士顿南区成长。
John Simpkins grew up in Lexington, South Carolina, a small town in a segregated black neighborhood. It was tightly knit. On his block, six of the houses were relatives. But when he went away to college at Harvard, he found that other black students had a very different picture of what it meant to be black in America.
约翰·辛普金斯（John Simpkins）在南卡罗来纳州的列克星敦长大，那是一个种族隔离的黑人社区中的小镇。社区关系非常紧密。在他那个街区，六栋房子的主人都是亲戚。但当他去哈佛上大学时，他发现其他黑人学生对在美国“做黑人”的意义有着非常不同的看法。
The students who weren't from small towns had this very definite image of blackness and what it meant to be an African American. And in most cases, that image was rooted more in Western Africa, or in Africa in general, instead of the South. And I thought the ironic thing was that students who weren't from the South tended to look down upon the South if you weren't from Miami or Atlanta or one of the huge Southern cities. Anyone who wasn't from any of those areas was viewed as being kind of backward.
那些不是来自小镇的学生对“黑人性”以及身为非裔美国人的意义有着非常明确的界定。在大多数情况下，那种印象更多地植根于西非，或者整个非洲，而不是南方。我觉得讽刺的是，那些不是来自南方的人，往往会看不起南方，除非你来自迈阿密、亚特兰大或南方的大城市。任何不是来自这些地区的人，都被视为有点落后。
In their view, was it almost an inauthentic black experience?
在他们看来，那几乎是一种“不地道”的黑人经历吗？
I think they viewed it as being a powerless black experience. There was an embrace of this sort of radical black nationalism, at least the words of radical black nationalism, with very little of the actions of radical black nationalism.
我认为他们将其视为一种“无权势”的黑人经历。他们拥护某种激进的黑人民族主义，至少是那些口号，但几乎没有任何激进黑人民族主义的行动。
What did their backgrounds tend to be? Where were they from?
他们的背景通常是什么样的？他们来自哪里？
Most of them tended to be from cities, mostly Northern cities. A lot of them were from, at least in my mind, fairly well-off or at least middle-class families.
他们大多数人来自城市，主要是北方城市。在我的印象中，很多来自相当富裕或至少是中产阶级的家庭。
And as far as you were concerned, was it that the sense of identity and group identity that they wanted, that's something you felt like you just had when you were growing up in the South in a small town?
就你而言，他们所追求的那种身份认同感和群体认同感，是你觉得你在南方小镇成长时就已经拥有的吗？
Right.
对。
We do live in a community where we're the only black family on this block. Now, the school that our boys go to is a thoroughly integrated school. 25% of the student body is Japanese-speaking. But the kind of close-knit and all-encompassing experience of a black community, which both my wife and I knew growing up, is not something that they're ever going to have. And yet, we think the issue of race is sufficiently important. We want them to be able to feel comfortable with their racial identity, to be able to not have to get to be 18 years old and then go off to college and all of a sudden determine that they're going to have to find out what this blackness is about.
我们确实住在一个社区，我们是这个街区唯一的黑人家庭。当然，我们的儿子去的学校是一所彻底融合的学校，25%的学生是说日语的。但是，我和我妻子成长过程中那种紧密联系且包罗万象的黑人社区体验，是不可能让他们拥有的。然而，我们认为种族问题非常重要。我们希望他们能对自己的种族身份感到自在，不必等到18岁去上大学，才突然决定要弄清楚这“黑人性”是怎么回事。
That was one of the more disturbing aspects of it. And that there was this attitude of hip radicalism embraced by people who really hadn't experienced what it meant to be on the other side of that coin.
那是其中最令人不安的方面之一。那是那种被那些根本没经历过这一面的人所拥护的“潮人式激进主义”。
The other side being?
所谓的“另一面”是指？
Being growing up either-- whether in the city or even in a small town-- in a lower-middle-class or lower-class family.
成长在城市，或者即使是在小镇，也是在低中产阶级或低阶层家庭中成长。
And did you view a lot of this as just posing?
你认为其中很多只是在装模作样吗？
I viewed a lot of it as posing. And I thought that there was little opportunity to discuss the range of what it meant to be a black person in America.
我觉得很多都是在装模作样。我认为讨论“在美国做一个黑人”的广度，机会很少。
I mean, one of the things that my wife and I live most in fear of is that having neglected attention to this question earlier in the children's life, they will then rebel later on and lapse into some kind of formulaic blackness that is stilted and narrow. We want them to think you can learn the Japanese language, or the Arabic language, for that matter, or you can learn to play the cello and still be black. There's nothing un-black or uncool about any of those activities.
我是说，我和我妻子最担心的就是，如果在孩子的生活中忽视了这个问题，他们以后会反叛，滑向某种呆板而狭隘的“公式化黑人形象”。我们希望他们明白你可以学习日语，或者阿拉伯语，甚至可以学习演奏大提琴，同时依然保持黑人身份。这些活动中没有什么不“黑”或不“酷”的。
Is there a part of you where you feel like your kids are missing something by not growing up in a segregated black community?
你是否觉得你的孩子没有在一个种族隔离的黑人社区长大，而错过了什么？
Yeah. They're missing something. But it's OK. This is the way of the world. There are benefits and there are costs. And I think the costs outweigh the benefits of living in that kind of society.
是的。他们错过了一些东西。但没关系。这就是世界运作的方式。有收益就有成本。我认为生活在那样的社会中，成本大于收益。
Our kids take a lot of stuff for granted. They just assume that the world is their oyster. They don't have to overcome some barriers or to make some discovery that they can do anything. They take it for granted that everything is possible for them. And I don't think that kind of sensibility can be fostered when you're living in a ghetto. It's very clear that everything is not possible for you. That's why it's a ghetto.
我们的孩子把很多东西视为理所当然。他们只是觉得世界是他们的天下。他们不需要克服什么障碍，或者去发现他们能做任何事。他们认为一切对他们来说都是可能的。我不认为当你在贫民窟生活时，那种感觉能被培养出来。很明显，并非一切对你都是可能的。这就是为什么它叫贫民窟。
A lot of them grew up in integrated environments. And in a few cases, there were even kids who had gone to the best schools and had the best educations, from Exeter or Andover, schools of that sort, who came to college. And it became their political awakening. But what I found interesting was that once college was over, they returned to this lifestyle that they had led before they left to go to college.
他们中的许多人是在融合环境中长大的。在少数情况下，甚至有些孩子读过最好的学校，受过最好的教育，比如埃克塞特或安多弗那样的学校，然后来到大学。这成了他们的政治觉醒。但我发现有趣的是，一旦大学毕业，他们又回到了去大学之前那种生活方式。
Explain that a little more. What do you mean?
再解释一下。你是说？
This is where a lot of the comparisons between the black middle class, or the black student population at Harvard, and the white middle-class students really comes into play. Especially during the '60s, when a lot of white students went away to school and engaged in experimental activity, they left and took jobs in the corporate world. Or a lot of people would say that they sold out. And I don't even think that that's necessarily the case. But the same things happened with the black students at Harvard, in that there was a lot of posturing. It was a heavily politicized environment. But really once the rubber met the road, those were the same students who took jobs on Wall Street or who went to law school or who went to business school.
这就是黑人中产阶级或者哈佛黑人学生群体与白人中产阶级学生之间对比体现的地方。特别是在60年代，当很多白人学生去上大学并参与实验性活动时，他们毕业后进入了企业界，或者很多人会说他们“出卖了理想”。我甚至不认为那一定就是事实。但黑人学生在哈佛也发生了同样的事，有很多姿态上的做作。那是一个高度政治化的环境。但当真正面对现实时，他们也是那些去华尔街找工作、或者去读法学院、商学院的学生。
So their college activism was just a little pleasurable hiatus from the identities that they had had before and the identities they were going to have after?
所以他们的大学激进主义只是从他们之前拥有的身份以及未来将要拥有的身份中，偷来的一段令人愉快的间歇？
Right. Right.
没错。没错。
I know that my boys will be black in a way so very different from that which characterized my own life. And my thinking now is that the best thing is that they wear that racial identity lightly. Not that they'd be indifferent to their blackness or ashamed of it, or look at it as an irrelevancy, but that I'd hope that they would be able to be black in a way that leaves them flexible and adaptable and open and not parochial and narrow.
我知道我的儿子们作为一个黑人的方式，将与我自己的生活方式大不相同。我现在的想法是，最好的事情就是让他们轻松地看待那种种族身份。不是说他们要对自己的黑人身份漠不关心、引以为耻，或者认为它不重要，而是我希望他们能以一种灵活、适应力强、开放、而非狭隘和闭塞的方式成为黑人。
Glenn Loury and John Simpkins. Coming up, a man calls Robert De Niro chicken to his face. Well, not really to his face, but it's still kind of interesting. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
格伦·洛里和约翰·辛普金斯。接下来，一个男人当面称罗伯特·德尼罗为“胆小鬼”。嗯，并不是真的当面，但仍然很有意思。公共广播国际的节目将在片刻后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of different kinds of people to tackle that theme with a variety of different kinds of stories. Today's program, The Real Thing, stories of people trying to live up to some ideal, or refusing to. We have arrived at Act Three of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种各样的人用各种各样的故事来处理这个主题。今天节目主题是《真东西》，讲述人们试图活出某种理想，或拒绝活出理想的故事。现在进行到节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Drawl. There are tens of millions of real Southerners in this country. They shop. They live among us. They look just like you and me, my friend. But one industry does not seem to notice the reality. Writer Mark Schone is a Southern expatriate who has noticed.
第三幕，《腔调》。在这个国家有数千万真实的南方人。他们会购物，生活在我们中间。朋友们，他们看起来和你我一样。但有一个行业似乎没注意到这个现实。作家马克·肖恩（Mark Schone）是一位注意到这一点的南方侨民。
My wife and I, since we'd been in lock-down with each other, oh, these past nine years, have developed a bit of shorthand. If one of us says something the other has heard so many times before that tears of boredom flow, the victim has a right to protest. The victim says, "That's on the tape." As in, that's on your tape-- the list of stories and obsessions you've rewound so often I could sing along with them in my sleep.
我和我妻子，自从我们互相“封锁”在一起，噢，这过去的九年里，已经形成了一点速记法。如果其中一人说了一些对方听过太多遍以至于感到无聊至极的话，受害者有权抗议。受害者会说：“那在录音带里呢。”意思是，那是你的录音带——你重放过太多次的那些故事和执念清单，我已经能在睡梦中跟着唱了。
But if we're lying in the queen size at night watching TV and chance on some misbegotten soup of dropped R's and fake I's that's supposed to be a Southern accent, my tape starts jumping. It must be heard. I must blurt, "Foghorn Leghorn. Foghorn Leghorn."
但如果我们晚上躺在双人床上看电视，偶然听到某种被省略掉的R音和虚假的I音混合成的“南方口音”，我的录音带就开始跳针。必须被听到。我必须大喊：“莱格霍恩大公鸡（Foghorn Leghorn）。莱格霍恩大公鸡。”
My wife says, "Tape," and we change the channel.
我妻子说：“录音带。”于是我们换台。
For me, all that is cornball about movie Southern accents, all that is fake, is embodied by that would-be mac daddy of the barnyard, the animated chicken known as Foghorn Leghorn. He was conceived as a parody of the genteel Old South cliches from movies like Gone With the Wind . He was a preening dandy and a fool for the ladies.
对我而言，电影南方口音中所有虚假、老套的东西，都体现在那个农场界的“幕后大佬”——名为莱格霍恩大公鸡的动画鸡身上。他最初被构思为《乱世佳人》等电影中那种温文尔雅的旧南方陈词滥调的戏仿。他是一个虚荣的花花公子，一个女人的傻瓜。
Go away, boy. You bother me. I got work to do.
走开，小伙子。你烦到我了。我还有事要忙。
The late, legendary Mel Blanc didn't try and do an actual Southern accent.
已故的传奇人物梅尔·布兰克（Mel Blanc）并没有尝试去模仿真正的南方口音。
You better, I say, you better keep a sharp eye on us chickens.
你最好，我是说，你最好盯着我们这些鸡，放机灵点。
He was spread thin being a martian and a putty tat and a tweety bird. And this was a satire starring a big white rooster. It wasn't about sounding real. 60 years later, though, actors are still speaking Foghorn, and they think it is real.
他又是演火星人，又是演猫咪，又是演崔弟鸟，分身乏术。这是一部以一只大白公鸡为主角的讽刺剧。它不是为了听起来真实。然而60年后，演员们依然在说着“莱格霍恩腔”，而且他们以为这是真实的。
I'm an authority on Southern accents because I'm a typical, rootless, modern Southerner, meaning I was born outside the South, just like Newt Gingrich and Dick Armey, and moved as a kid with my Midwestern parents to a brand new subdivision chopped out of the swamp in Southeastern Virginia. A babysitter taught me what y'all meant when I was seven years old. In high school, my rebellion against my liberal college professor dad was to hang out with drug-dealing rednecks. I whimpered in the backseat with a beer clenched between my thighs as they drove the back roads at 100 miles per hour, swerving through the swamp fog, their eyes closed and giggling. But as long as they looked and talked like Allen Collins of Lynyrd Skynyrd, as long as they had that mean, feral glamour, I thought they were cool. I talked like them on purpose. It thrilled me when a guy on my school bus grunted, "Groundhog? My mama don't eat it but my daddy do."
我是南方口音方面的权威，因为我是一个典型的、漂泊的、现代南方人，意思是我出生在南方之外，就像纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）和迪克·阿米（Dick Armey）一样，小时候随着我的中西部父母搬到了弗吉尼亚州东南部从沼泽地开辟出来的一个全新住宅区。7岁时，保姆教了我“y'all”（你们大家）的意思。高中时，我对那位自由派大学教授父亲的反叛，就是和贩毒的乡下佬混在一起。当他们开着车以每小时100英里的速度穿过沼泽浓雾，闭着眼睛咯咯傻笑时，我紧紧攥着两腿间的啤酒瑟瑟发抖。但只要他们看起来和听起来像Lynyrd Skynyrd乐队的艾伦·柯林斯（Allen Collins），只要他们拥有那种邪恶、狂野的魅力，我就觉得他们很酷。我故意学他们说话。校车上的一个家伙咕哝道：“土拨鼠？我妈不吃，但我爸吃。”这让我感到无比兴奋。
I went to college 1,000 miles away in Nashville and heard a stronger, twangier accent than the coastal burr I grew up with. And I moved to Georgia for a few more years of seasoning. By the time I left the South, I had a pretty good grasp of the range of regional dialects. And I knew that the movies had them all comically wrong. I would argue that nearly every vowel that comes out of nearly every actor's mouth is wrong. But for outsiders, here are the easiest problems to spot. Let's take Keanu Reeves in Devil's Advocate .
我在离家1000英里的纳什维尔上大学，听到了比我成长过程中那种沿海口音更强、更带鼻音的腔调。我在佐治亚州又住了几年，进一步历练。当我离开南方时，我已经相当了解该地区方言的范围了。而且我知道电影把它们都搞错了。我想说的是，几乎每个演员嘴里吐出的每一个元音都是错的。但对于外行来说，以下是最容易发现的问题。我们拿《魔鬼代言人》里的基努·里维斯举例。
Is it your testimony, Ms. Black, that between the hours of 6:10 and 9:40, you were engaged in sexual congress with the defendant?
你的证词是，布莱克小姐，在6点10分到9点40分之间，你与被告发生了性关系？
Well, maybe that's too easy. How about someone who has never actually turned down a script, like Dan Aykroyd. He played the son in Driving Miss Daisy .
嗯，也许那个太容易了。试试看那个从未拒绝过剧本的人，比如丹·艾克罗伊德（Dan Aykroyd）。他在《为黛西小姐开车》里扮演儿子。
I'm afraid that my loss up here and my gain down here have given me an air of competence I don't really possess.
恐怕我在这里的损失和在那里的收益，给了我一种我不具备的能力感。
Leaving aside all the other things wrong with this way-Foghorn soundbite, very few white people in the South still drop their R's. They say "Here," not "Heeya." A linguist at the University of Georgia told me, "If you want to find somebody with that old plantation accent, you're talking about people 75 years old."
撇开这种“莱格霍恩式”配音的其他错误不谈，南方很少有白人还在省略R音了。他们说“Here”（这里），而不是“Heeya”。一位佐治亚大学的语言学家告诉我：“如果你想找那种老种植园口音的人，那是75岁以上的老人。”
A friend in Atlanta was more emphatic. "Those people are dead. Before they died, they were rich. Or they lived in the coastal or Piedmont areas of the South. Up in the hills, they always said their R's. And now, in the age of seven hours of TV a day and the air conditioner and the massive influx of interlopers like me and Newt and Dick, nearly every white devil in the South has followed suit, especially white devils under 50. We say R.
亚特兰大的一个朋友语气更坚决。“那些人已经死了。在他们死前，他们很有钱。或者他们住在南方的沿海或皮埃蒙特地区。在山区，他们总是发R音。现在，在每天看7小时电视、空调普及以及像我和纽特、迪克这样的人大量涌入的时代，南方几乎每个白人魔鬼都顺应了潮流，尤其是50岁以下的白人魔鬼。我们发R音。”
Lesson two.
第二课。
My name's Forrest. Forrest Gump. My mama always said that life was like a box of chocolates.
我叫福雷斯特。福雷斯特·甘（Forrest Gump）。我妈妈常说，人生就像一盒巧克力。
There are two kinds of I's. The I sound in a word like "life," or "like," or "night," or "nice," is different from the I in "five," or "ride," or "time." Real Southerners make a distinction between the I's. My experience in three states over 20 years was that they said "life," and they said "time." "Lifetime," not "laff-tahm." Not many people said, "laff," or "lahck." If they did, they were considered hillbillies. And in fact, they almost always really did hail from Appalachia or maybe a piney wood town in East Texas. But in the movies, even a kid from a fine, old, big-columned Alabama home-- like Forrest Gump-- says, "Laff is lack a box of chocolates."
I音有两种。像“life”（生活）、“like”（喜欢）、“night”（夜晚）或“nice”（好）里的I音，与“five”（五）、“ride”（骑）、“time”（时间）里的I音是不同的。真正的南方人会区分这些I音。我在三个州生活了20年的经历是，他们说“life”，也说“time”。是“Lifetime”，而不是“laff-tahm”。没有多少人说“laff”或“lahck”。如果他们说了，那会被认为是乡下人。事实上，他们几乎确实来自阿巴拉契亚或者德克萨斯东部的松林镇。但在电影里，即使是一个来自阿拉巴马州有着精美老式大圆柱豪宅的孩子——比如福雷斯特·甘——也会说，“Laff is lack a box of chocolates”（人生就像一盒巧克力）。
Life was like a box of chocolates.
人生就像一盒巧克力。
Lesson three, the South is really big. People from Savannah and the coal fields and the Bayou don't talk the same. And they're not usually in the same room, unless they're on vacation in Florida, which is another part of the South. But in the movies, people with radically different accents turn out to be mother and daughter or lifelong neighbors. Listen to the way Dolly Parton, Sally Fields, and Julia Roberts pronounce "color" in Steel Magnolias. Fields is supposed to be Roberts' mother.
第三课，南方真的很大。萨凡纳、煤矿区和河口的口音都不一样。而且他们通常不会待在同一个房间里，除非是在佛罗里达度假，那是南方的另一个部分。但在电影里，说话腔调截然不同的人往往被设定为母女或终身邻居。听听多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）、莎莉·菲尔德（Sally Fields）和朱莉娅·罗伯茨（Julia Roberts）在《钢木兰》中是怎么发“color”（颜色）这个词的。菲尔德被设定为罗伯茨的母亲。
What are your colors, Shelby?
你选的是什么颜色，谢尔比（Shelby）？
Her colors are pink and pink.
她的颜色是粉色和粉色。
My colors are blush and bashful, Mama.
我的颜色是红晕色和害羞色，妈妈。
Once upon a time, I couldn't figure out why the actors and directors in LA and New York couldn't spend any time listening to actual Southerners talk. Because if they did, they'd learn very quickly how far the film dialect had drifted from reality. But after I moved to New York, I realized that I was just living amid hicks again. This time they were urban hicks, and the world outside their hollow was one big movie set.
曾几何时，我无法理解为什么洛杉矶和纽约的演员和导演不能花点时间听听真正的南方人说话。因为如果他们听了，很快就会知道电影方言已经偏离现实有多远了。但在搬到纽约后，我意识到我只是又生活在乡下人中间了。这一次他们是“城市乡下人”，而他们的小圈子外面的世界就是一个巨大的电影布景。
The South was a movie. If you went there, you spoke a language invented by a British woman named Vivien Leigh, also known as Scarlett or Blanche, with an assist by New Jersey's Rod Steiger as the racist sheriff, and San Francisco's Mel Blanc as that uppity chicken. The South was a cartoon.
南方是一部电影。如果你去那里，你说的语言是由一位名叫费雯·丽（Vivien Leigh，又名斯嘉丽或布兰奇）的英国女性发明出来的，加上新泽西州的罗德·斯泰格（Rod Steiger）饰演的种族主义警长，以及旧金山的梅尔·布兰克饰演的那只高傲的公鸡的辅助。南方是一个卡通片。
I admit, the natives played along. They scammed the hicks by selling more and more preposterous stories about white columns and crazy aunts in the attic. They cooked up as much Gothic kitsch as the market would bear. A guy from St. Louis renamed himself Tennessee and made a mint. It was a great racket, but it meant that Southerners never really saw themselves on screen. They still don't.
我承认，本地人也配合演出了。他们通过兜售越来越多关于白圆柱和阁楼里疯狂姑妈的离谱故事来欺骗这些乡下佬。他们制造了尽可能多的哥特式媚俗，只要市场能承受。一个来自圣路易斯的家伙给自己改名“田纳西”，赚了一大笔钱。这真是一场伟大的骗局，但这也意味着南方人从未真正在屏幕上看到过自己。他们至今都没有。
Counselor, is that you?
律师，是你吗？
It was the remake of Cape Fear that gave me my moment of clarity. I hunkered in a Manhattan multiplex awestruck. Robert De Niro was trying to impersonate a dirt-eating psycho. And yes, it was nuts. But not the way De Niro intended.
是《恐怖角》的翻拍版给了我顿悟的时刻。我缩在曼哈顿的一家多厅影院里，敬畏不已。罗伯特·德尼罗正试图模仿一个吃土的变态。是的，那确实疯了，但不是德尼罗想要的那种疯法。
Come out, come out, wherever you are.
出来，出来，不管你在哪里。
New York mook was bumping uglies with Cajun and Carolina. It was the worst thing I'd ever heard. I rolled in it like a happy doggy with something dead.
纽约混混在和卡津（Cajun）和卡罗莱纳的口音杂交。这是我听过的最糟糕的东西。我像一只快乐的小狗在死物上打滚一样，乐在其中。
It's going to take a hell of a lot more than that, counselor, to prove you're better than me.
律师，那需要比这多得多的功夫，才能证明你比我强。
When it was over and the credits drifted past, I locked onto the one that read Dialect Coach. Now I knew. After that, every time Foghorn turned up in a movie, I'd check to see who his dialect coach was. Every Southern ex-pat I knew came out of Cape Fear going, "Huh?" But the man who taught De Niro to sound like an Appalachian Springsteen was so proud he bragged about it. I would see his ads in the showbiz trade papers and get all twitchy. "To Robert De Niro, congratulations, Sam Chwat."
当电影结束，演职员表飘过时，我的目光锁定在“方言教练”那一行。现在我知道了。之后，每次莱格霍恩大公鸡出现在电影里，我都会查查他的方言教练是谁。我认识的每个南方侨民看完《恐怖角》后都会说：“哈？”但那个教德尼罗发出阿巴拉契亚式斯普林斯汀口音的人，却对此引以为傲，甚至大肆吹嘘。我会在演艺行业的贸易报纸上看到他的广告，感到一阵抽搐。“向罗伯特·德尼罗致敬，恭喜山姆·查特（Sam Chwat）。”
Well, my name is Sam Chwat. I'm Director of New York Speech Improvement Services. We're the largest company of licensed speech therapists in this country to, uh-- tsk. We're the largest company of licensed speech therapists in the United States, specializing in accent acquisition and accent elimination.
嗯，我的名字是山姆·查特。我是纽约演讲改进服务公司的总监。我们是这个国家最大的执业言语治疗师公司，专门从事——啧——我们是美国最大的执业言语治疗师公司，专注于口音习得和口音消除。
I dropped in on Chwat at his Manhattan offices, where boxes of celebrity junk spilled onto the floor. He was born and raised in Brooklyn speaking Yiddish, and he's never lived more than an hour from Grand Central. But he has a Masters in speech and 20 years of experience in accents. At first, he specialized in removing them. Then he started doing implants.
我走访了查特在曼哈顿的办公室，那里到处都是名人的垃圾，溢到了地板上。他是在布鲁克林出生长大的，说的是意第绪语，从未离开中央车站超过一小时。但他拥有言语治疗硕士学位，并有20年的口音研究经验。起初，他专门消除口音。后来，他开始做“植入”。
I trained Robert De Niro to do an Appalachian accent for Cape Fear . Leonardo DiCaprio, a New York accent for Basketball Diaries . Julia Roberts and Andie MacDowell lost their Southern accents with me before their film careers began. Elle Macpherson, Kathleen Turner, Benjamin Bratt, a wide variety of people.
我训练罗伯特·德尼罗为《恐怖角》练习阿巴拉契亚口音。莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥为《篮球日记》练习纽约口音。朱莉娅·罗伯茨和安迪·麦克道威尔在电影生涯开始前就和我一起去掉了南方口音。艾丽·麦克弗森、凯瑟琳·特纳、本杰明·布拉特，形形色色的人。
What would you say you're best at amongst the accents that you know?
在你所知的口音中，你觉得你最擅长哪一种？
I suppose my Italian is all right, you know? My Italian itself is not so good, you know? But I do a pretty good Italian.
我想我的意大利语还行吧，你知道？我的意大利语本身其实不是很好，你知道？但我能模仿得很像意大利人。
His Southern accent was every bit as convincing. He told me he had a whole posse of relatives down in Savannah who taught him the local lingo. He demonstrated.
他的南方口音也同样令人信服。他告诉我，他在萨凡纳有一大帮亲戚教他当地的土话。他做了演示。
It depends on the sort of Southern accent you're talkin' about. If it's an Appalachian sort of accent, it's one that I've taught many, many times. There's a kind of broad-based one, more indicative of, say, the deep South, where the R's disappear after the vowel, let's say.
这取决于你说的哪种南方口音。如果是阿巴拉契亚那种口音，我已经教过很多很多次了。有一种基础广泛的，更能代表所谓“深南地区”的口音，即元音后的R音消失了。
Which is Hollywood Southern in a nutshell. It's the way people in movies talk, not people in real life. I told Chwat I'd never met anyone who spoke with the thing he was calling a Southern accent. I pointed out that the people who drop their R's were not the same people as the ones who said, "Lack," and now the R-less people were almost extinct anyway. He defended himself. He backpedaled. And often, he stayed silent. He told me I had a sensitive ear. But it doesn't take a sensitive ear. Listen to this clip from one of his star clients.
这就是好莱坞南方口音的缩影。这是电影里人们说话的方式，而不是现实中人们说话的方式。我告诉查特，我从未见过任何用他称之为“南方口音”说话的人。我指出，那些省略R音的人和那些说“Lack”（像）的人根本不是同一类人，而且现在省略R音的人几乎已经绝迹了。他为自己辩护。他退缩了。而且经常，他保持沉默。他告诉我我的耳朵很敏感。但这不需要敏锐的耳朵。听听他的一位明星客户的这段剪辑。
If my daddy catches you in here, the question of whether or not I can carry your children will not matter. He will cut your thing off.
如果我爸爸抓到你在这儿，我能不能生你的孩子这种问题就没意义了。他会把你那玩意儿切掉。
That's Julia Roberts in Steel Magnolias . A linguist will tell you that a middle-class 20-something in that town, in that recent year, would say her R's. She'd say, "whether" and "your," and "matter." A linguist told me that. But Chwat has bought into the cartoon so completely, he thinks Roberts herself used to talk that way when she was growing up in suburban Atlanta. He claims that back before she was a star, when he helped her get rid of her Southern accent, here were the things he had to fix.
那是《钢木兰》里的朱莉娅·罗伯茨。语言学家会告诉你，那个小镇、那个近年的中产阶级20多岁女性会发R音。她会说“whether”、“your”和“matter”。语言学家是这样告诉我的。但查特已经完全买账了那种卡通式的设定，他认为罗伯茨本人在亚特兰大郊区长大时就是那样说话的。他声称，在她成名之前，当他帮她去掉南方口音时，以下是他必须修复的地方。
Pretty garden-variety Southern substitutions. "Tin," instead of "ten." The "ah" for "I." Dropping an R after a vowel-- "heeya," "theya," "moh," instead of "here," "there," or "more."
都是些南方常见的替换词。“Tin”代替“ten”（十）。用“ah”代替“I”。元音后丢弃R——说“heeya”、“theya”、“moh”，而不是“here”、“there”或“more”。
Except, of course, she didn't talk that way. If you want confirmation, all you have to do is ask someone who knew her then.
当然，除了她根本不是那样说话的。如果你想要确认，你只需问问当时认识她的人。
I've been a guidance counselor at Campbell High School for 21 years.
我在坎贝尔高中做了21年的升学顾问。
I asked Richard Epps, a guidance counselor at her Smyrna, Georgia high school, who doesn't talk that way either.
我问了理查德·艾普斯（Richard Epps），她是乔治亚州士麦那高中的升学顾问，他说话也不那样。
She was a student here. And she was a student aide in our office.
她是这儿的学生。还是我们办公室的学生助手。
So you had daily contact with her?
所以你和她有日常接触？
Yes. Surely did.
是的。当然。
Now, this'll be your 21st year.
算上今年，这将是你第21个年头了吧。
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
In the 21 years that you've been at Campbell High School, have you had any white students who dropped their R's?
在你去坎贝尔高中的21年里，有没有遇到过任何丢掉R音的白人学生？
I don't recall any of that at all. I don't recall any, to tell you the truth.
实话实说，我根本记不得有这回事。
How about Julia? Did Julia ever drop her R's?
朱莉娅呢？朱莉娅丢过R音吗？
Absolutely not.
绝对没有。
And that's why Roberts sounds so fake when she drops them in Steel Magnolias . Because she's never done it before. I guess what happened is that when she showed up on set with her own real, suburban drawl, it wasn't close enough to the cartoon for the powers that be, and they sent for Chwat. It's like something out of the movie Hollywood Shuffle , some white guy telling a black actor, "Um, can you make that blacker?"
这就是为什么罗伯茨在《钢木兰》中省略R音时听起来那么假。因为她以前从没那样说过话。我想发生的事情是，当她带着自己真实的、郊区式的拖长腔出现在片场时，这对于决策者来说不够“卡通”，于是他们请来了查特。这就像电影《好莱坞乱套》里的情节，某个白人对黑人演员说：“嗯，你能让它更黑人一点吗？”
One reason Hollywood can't get Southern right is that Southern won't hold still. The real South is changing. Real Southerners go to malls and eat at The Olive Garden. The media tells them that the way they speak is either quaint or a symptom of Gomer-dom. So if they're the slightest bit upwardly mobile, they try not to sound too you-know-what.
好莱坞无法掌握南方口音的原因之一是，南方口音不会保持不变。真实的南方正在改变。真正的南方人去商场，去“橄榄花园”餐厅吃饭。媒体告诉他们，他们说话的方式要么很古雅，要么是“戈默式”低智的征兆。所以如果他们有一点点向上流动的意识，他们就会尽量让自己听起来别那么“你知道的”。
Sometimes Hollywood does make a semi-honest effort to keep it real. Robert De Niro listened to real people speak for his role in Cape Fear. He sent his personal assistant into a Southern prison to tape interviews with inmates of the same age, criminal record, and hillbilly bona fides as his character in the script. He picked a tape he liked and labored with Sam Chwat for weeks to perfect his imitation. Sometimes, however, the will, the intent, the technique is flawless, and the flesh still fails.
有时好莱坞确实会做出半真半诚的努力来保持真实。罗伯特·德尼罗在《恐怖角》的角色中听了真实的人说话。他派私人助理进入南方监狱，录下了年龄、犯罪记录和“乡下佬血统”与剧本角色相同的人的采访。他选了一盘他喜欢的录音，和山姆·查特一起苦练数周，以完善他的模仿。然而有时，意志、意图、技术都完美无瑕，但肉体却依然失败了。
I am like God, and God like me. I am as large as God. He is as small as I. He cannot above me nor I beneath him be.
我如上帝，上帝如我。我如上帝般伟大。他如我般渺小。他不能高于我，我也不能低于他。
Some actors just can't do accents.
有些演员就是模仿不了口音。
Counselor?
律师？
Writer Mark Schone is a reporter living among the Yankees in New York City, hoping not to run into a certain actor.
作家马克·肖恩是一位居住在纽约市的记者，生活在扬基人中间，希望别碰到某个特定的演员。
[MUSIC- "SOUTHERN ACCENTS" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐- 《南方口音》 约翰尼·卡什（Johnny Cash）]
Act Four, Real Love. There's the real thing when it comes to your idea of what job you want, what house you want, what person you want to fall in love with. And until you find the real thing that you seek, life is the same story over and over and over again, either played as comedy or as tragedy. A story of missing the real thing yet again. In one of our live shows, Los Angeles writer and performer Sandra Tsing Loh tells what happened to her when she signed up for a computer dating service. A folder arrived with a name and some vital stats.
第四幕，《真爱》。当你想要什么样的工作、什么样的房子、想和什么样的人坠入爱河时，都有所谓“真东西”的存在。而在你找到所追求的那个“真东西”之前，生活就是同样的故事一遍又一遍地重复，要么是喜剧，要么是悲剧。一个又一次错过“真东西”的故事。在我们的一次现场秀中，洛杉矶作家兼表演者桑德拉·清·洛（Sandra Tsing Loh）讲述了当她报名参加计算机交友服务时发生的事情。一份装有名单和个人资料的文件夹送达了。
Robert Blair, 37, single. I look in his folder and I can't believe it. My mouth goes dry. For one thing, unlike what you'd expect from a dating service, Robert Blair is really, really attractive. No, I mean really. Straight nose, clean jaw line, smoldering blue eyes. We are talking Ralph Fiennes. Ralph Fiennes has basically donned a crew neck sweater and is living among us in the Southland.
罗伯特·布莱尔，37岁，单身。我翻开他的文件夹，简直不敢相信。我口干舌燥。一方面，与你对交友服务的预期不同，罗伯特·布莱尔真的、真的很有吸引力。不，我是说真的。笔挺的鼻子，干净的下颌线，忧郁的蓝眼睛。我们在谈论拉尔夫·费因斯（Ralph Fiennes）。拉尔夫·费因斯基本上穿上了一件圆领毛衣，生活在我们南方的平民百姓中间。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I turn the page. Robert Blair is an architect by profession. Time has been spent in Italy. Interests include opera, foreign movies, badminton. Marital status-- never. My heart is pounding. My eyes are tearing up. Oh my god, I'm thinking. Oh my god. And this panic is starting to seize me. Not just the primary panic of having found the perfect man, but the secondary panic of knowing that other women are looking at this perfect man, and then the tertiary panic of realizing that I'm feeling this panic.
我翻开下一页。罗伯特·布莱尔是建筑师。他在意大利待过。兴趣包括歌剧、外国电影、羽毛球。婚姻状况——未婚。我的心跳加速。眼眶湿润。噢天哪，我想着。噢天哪。这种恐慌开始攫住我。不仅仅是找到了完美男人的基本恐慌，还有意识到其他女人也在盯着这个完美男人的二级恐慌，以及意识到自己正在感到恐慌的三级恐慌。
And when you feel panic, dates don't tend to go well. Somehow the panic invades your face causing these contortions to happen in the middle of some casual comment like, would you like some half-and-half? Equal? Your face will split open and this demon, this [DEMON VOICE], will come out. And in that instant, you have done it, that terrible, unthinkable thing. You have pierced the dating membrane, that is, the membrane that covers all dating people and keeps them safe from each other.
当你感到恐慌时，约会往往进行不顺。不知何故，恐慌会侵入你的脸庞，导致你在说一些随意评论时发生扭曲，比如，“你要半加半吗？甜味剂？”你的脸会裂开，这只恶魔[恶魔声音]就会跳出来。那一瞬间，你就做到了那件可怕、不可想象的事。你刺破了“约会膜”，也就是覆盖所有约会中男女、保护他们免受彼此伤害的膜。
As illustration, take Phillip, a perfect Los Feliz bachelor I was privileged to date a few times. You know the type-- successful 36-year-old film editor, or something. Great haircut, zippy Hugo Boss jacket. You know, one of those smart, funny, presentable men who form that eerie, hollow-eyed, Children of the Corn phalanx across our fair city. Any-hoo, like others of his ilk, the perfect Phillip package was coated with this impenetrable dating membrane. To wit, you were supposed to see Phillip once a week at most, twice a month more typically. But you were never to contact him in between as though he were some sort of undercover spy. To phone him at work was to trigger that bomb thing.
举个例子，菲利普（Phillip），我曾有幸约会过几次的完美洛费兹（Los Feliz）单身汉。你知道那种类型——成功的36岁电影剪辑师什么的。很棒的发型，时髦的雨果博斯（Hugo Boss）夹克。你知道，那些在全市范围内形成那种怪异、目光空洞、就像《玉米田的小孩》方阵一样聪慧、有趣、体面的男人。总之，像他同类中的其他人一样，完美的菲利普套餐被这层坚不可摧的“约会膜”包裹着。也就是说，你每周最多见菲利普一次，一个月两次更常见。但你绝不能在中间联系他，仿佛他是什么秘密间谍。在工作时间打电话给他会触发那种“炸弹”。
Any-hoo, Phillip kept trying to train me in the new system. And I knew that I should get with it. I knew that it was the law of Dating-land and that if I didn't follow it, I would lose my all-important Dating-land citizenship. I wouldn't be allowed to go out on any more meaningless, un-fun dates such as these.
总之，菲利普一直试图在新系统中训练我。我知道我应该适应它。我知道这是“约会乐园”的法律，如果我不遵守，我就会失去重要的“约会乐园”公民身份。我就没资格再进行那些毫无意义、不快乐的约会了。
So Phillip would smile suavely the next morning, handing me my delicious, warm, fresh, pumpkin muffin to-go. "Call you in 10 days or so?"
所以第二天早上，菲利普会优雅地微笑，递给我美味、温暖、新鲜的南瓜松饼。“10天左右给你打电话？”
"10 days? That's almost two weeks," I'd stab at in alarm, eyes wide. Picture last night's mascara gone spookily raccoon-y.
“10天？那是快两周了，”我睁大眼睛，惊恐地抗议。想象一下昨晚的睫毛膏已经像浣熊一样晕开了。
"I'm out of town," he'd enunciate, as you do when telling a large, wattled, eager Labrador to sit but she cannot quite remember how.
“我出城了，”他清晰地发音，就像你告诉一只庞大、下垂、渴望的拉布拉多犬坐下，但它记不住怎么坐的时候那样。
He repeated the command, "I'm out of town. Out of town. In 10 days or so, I will call you. OK? I'll call you. Really." Oh, I remember the drill. Dutifully, I repeated the phrases he had taught me, unnatural as Arabic.
他重复了指令，“我出城了。出城。10天左右，我会打电话给你。好吗？我会给你打。真的。”噢，我记得那个套路。我恭顺地重复了他教我的那些短语，虽然像阿拉伯语一样不自然。
"Well, have a great time. Jeez, I've got a busy week too. Call me whenever. It is no problem at all." But once I got going, I just couldn't stop, so, "there's a phone. You call me. I won't call. No, no, no." Delivery became so broad, so garish, so Jo Anne Worley-like that like a rare stag in the woods, my perfect bachelor would be spooked. And after 10 days or so, Phillip did not call again.
“好吧，祝你玩得开心。天哪，我这一周也很忙。随便什么时候给我打都行。一点问题都没有。”但一旦我开了头，就停不下来了，所以又说，“这儿有电话。你给我打。我不会打的。不，不，不。”我的表演变得如此宽泛、如此花哨，像乔安妮·沃利（Jo Anne Worley）一样，以至于像森林里罕见的雄鹿一样，我完美的单身汉被吓坏了。10天左右过后，菲利普再也没打过电话。
But I'm not going to make that mistake tonight, oh no. For once in my life, things are going to be different. For once in my life, I'm going to be silent. The forest green door opens and there stands Robert Blair. Crisp white linen, pressed khakis, tortoise-shell rims. Oh my god, I think, feeling the force of gravity buckling my knees.
但我今晚不会犯那个错误，噢不。我有生以来第一次，事情会有所不同。有生以来第一次，我要保持沉默。深绿色的门打开了，罗伯特·布莱尔站在那里。清脆的白亚麻布，笔挺的卡其裤，玳瑁框眼镜。噢天哪，我想，感受到重力让我膝盖发软。
"Hello," is all I say, "Robert." With perfect manners, Robert Blair shows me around his perfect place. We are talking coved ceilings, Mexican Paver tile, totally redone hardwood floors, muted track lighting, Sub-Zero fridge, even a utility sunroom with a pull-out ironing board. You can almost hear a choir of angels singing.
“你好，”我只说了这句话，“罗伯特。”罗伯特·布莱尔带着完美的礼仪带我参观他完美的住所。我们在谈论拱形天花板、墨西哥铺路砖、重新铺好的硬木地板、静音轨道灯、Sub-Zero冰箱，甚至是一个带抽拉式熨衣板的公用阳光房。你几乎能听到天使唱诗班的歌声。
"Sandra," Robert says behind me, "would you like some champagne?" [SQUEAK]
“桑德拉，”罗伯特在我身后说，“你想来点香槟吗？”[吱吱声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And there stands Robert Blair with two gleaming flutes of champagne and an Italian, hand-painted, ceramic plate upon which he's arranged Gorgonzola cheese, grapes, and English water crackers in a perfect fan.
罗伯特·布莱尔站在那里，手里拿着两支闪亮的香槟长笛，还有一个意大利手工绘制的陶瓷盘，上面整齐地摆放着戈尔贡佐拉干酪、葡萄和英国水饼干，排成完美的扇形。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I am home, I find myself thinking. I am home.
我回家了，我发现自己在想。我回家了。
The bistro Robert takes me to is a delightful, intimate place aglow with little candles. "You like opera," I say.
罗伯特带我去的酒馆是一个令人愉快、私密的地方，闪烁着小蜡烛。我说，“你喜欢歌剧。”
"Yes," he says, "I do."
“是的，”他说，“我喜欢。”
"I've heard Madame Butterfly is coming to the music center. I saw something about it in the Los Angeles Times."
“我听说《蝴蝶夫人》要来音乐中心了。我在《洛杉矶时报》上看到过。”
"Really," he says, "Did you?"
“真的吗，”他说，“你看到了？”
"Maybe we could--" no. Too early. Retract. "It's just such a great opera is all. I love it. I love opera."
“也许我们可以……”不。太早了。收回。“这只是一部很棒的歌剧而已。我喜欢它。我喜欢歌剧。”
"Butterfly is alright," he says, "for a warhorse. Americans certainly insist on their favorites. I sometimes think if I'm forced to sit through another Boheme , I'll scream."
“蝴蝶夫人还可以，”他说，“作为一首老曲子。美国人确实坚持他们的最爱。我有时想，如果我被迫再看一遍《波希米亚人》，我会尖叫的。”
"Yes, I know what you mean. The opera world is all so exhausting, isn't it?"
“是的，我明白你的意思。歌剧世界太让人筋疲力尽了，不是吗？”
His smoldering blue eyes meet mine, lock. "Yes, my dear," he says. "Exhausting." What does that mean?
他忧郁的蓝眼睛与我的相遇、锁定。“是的，亲爱的，”他说，“筋疲力尽。”那是什么意思？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I think, wait a minute. Whoa, relax, breathe. The guy works a 10-hour day. He went to the trouble of laying out English water crackers for you in that perfect fan. It's not that he's not having fun. It's just that he's really, really tired. And now I remember this happy thing. OK, this is really good. In Robert's kitchen was this really, really fancy cappuccino maker, because cappuccino was his habit. That's what he called it. "My habit." And I think, that's what Robert Blair needs after dinner. Some caffeine, a lift.
我想，等一下。哇，放松，呼吸。这家伙工作了10个小时。他费尽心思为你把那些英国水饼干排成完美的扇形。不是他没玩开心，而是他真的、真的累了。现在我想起了这个开心的事。好的，这真的很好。在罗伯特的厨房里有这个非常、非常高级的卡布奇诺咖啡机，因为卡布奇诺是他的习惯。他是这么叫的。“我的习惯。”我想，这就是罗伯特·布莱尔晚饭后需要的。一点咖啡因，提提神。
But the thing is, we can't have it here. We can't have it in this restaurant, even though it's an Italian restaurant and espresso machines keep whirring, whirring, whirring around us. Because to prolong the date, to kick things to that higher level, we need to move to a new venue to do a new activity. My god, it's barely 8:20 and the guy is all yawning and looking at his watch and going--
但问题是，我们不能在这儿喝。我们不能在这家餐厅喝，尽管这是一家意大利餐厅，周围全是嗖嗖作响的浓缩咖啡机。因为为了延长约会，为了把事情推进到更高的水平，我们需要去一个新地点进行一项新活动。天哪，才8点20分，这家伙就在打呵欠，看着手表说——
"Cappuccino," I say brightly. "I guess you make a mean cup of it, huh?"
“卡布奇诺，”我明快地说，“我想你能做出一杯不错的，对吧？”
"Well," he says, but then that slightly closed expression crosses his face. He pushes up his glasses. "Well, no."
“嗯，”他说，但那种稍微封闭的表情掠过他的脸。他推了推眼镜。“嗯，不能。”
"But your machine," I say, "in your kitchen."
“但是你的机器，”我说，“在你的厨房里。”
"It doesn't work," he says abruptly.
“它坏了，”他突然说。
"It doesn't work?"
“它坏了？”
"No, it is not that it does not work. It is just that it needs a new filter, a new water filter."
“不，不是它不能用。只是它需要一个新的过滤器，一个新的水过滤器。”
"You don't just use the filtered water from the white Brita jug thing in your Sub-Zero fridge?"
“你不用Sub-Zero冰箱里那个白色Brita壶过滤的水吗？”
"Well, you could. But it is just not good."
“嗯，你可以。但它就是不好。”
"Well, I could go for some cappuccino," I forge on, hacking through the dense, rubbery foliage with my scimitar. "And you must be missing it if you can't make it at home. I know I miss things when I can't make them at home. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] I've got a great idea. Why don't we go to a great cappuccino bar I know just a short walk from here on La Brea?" Clutching his arm, my hand like a pinion, I see myself reflected in Robert Blair's perfect tortoise-shell glasses. My mascara is raccoony, hair a fright wig. I have come to my date dressed like a hyena, and I cannot stop talking.
“嗯，我可以喝点卡布奇诺，”我继续说，用我的弯刀砍向浓密、橡胶般的叶丛。“如果你在家做不了，你肯定会想念它的。我知道我做不了的时候会想念它们。[乱码短语]我有好主意。为什么我们不去拉布雷亚（La Brea）大道上那家我知道的很棒的卡布奇诺酒吧呢？”紧紧抓住他的胳膊，我的手像个插销，我看到自己在罗伯特·布莱尔完美的玳瑁眼镜里映出倒影。我的睫毛膏像浣熊一样晕开，头发像个惊悚假发。我穿着像只鬣狗一样来赴约，而且我无法停止说话。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"It was fun," Robert Blair says, giving me a quick peck on the cheek at the door. "Sorry about having to bail early. It's just that I'm really, really tired. But thank you." The forest green door shuts behind him, locks. There are footfalls. A moment later, a light goes on upstairs.
“很有趣，”罗伯特·布莱尔在门口给了我一个快速的脸颊吻。“抱歉得提前告辞了。只是我真的、真的累了。但谢谢你。”深绿色的门在他身后锁上了。有脚步声。片刻之后，楼上亮起了灯。
That moment, I realize that Robert Blair is completely happy behind that curtain, alone in the perfect palace he took such great pains in showing me. He is probably leaping about in boyish stockinged feet on his perfectly appointed couches, loveseats, and pillows, throwing his arms up, jubilant, free of the burden of me. It makes me furious. I begin to shake at the iron rods of the locked gate, shake them with all my might.
那一刻，我意识到罗伯特·布莱尔在那层窗帘后面是完全快乐的，独自待在他花了那么大心思展示给我的完美宫殿里。他可能正穿着袜子，像个男孩一样在他那些完美陈设的沙发、长椅和靠垫上跳来跳去，欢呼雀跃，从我的负担中解放出来。这让我狂怒。我开始摇晃那扇锁着的铁门，用尽全力摇晃。
"I am not done with this evening," I yell. "I am not done. You don't even have to talk to me. We don't even have to see each other again. But I want that cup of cappuccino. And I want it, uh, frothy!" But there was no answer. After a moment, ever so distantly behind double panes of glass, I hear it-- the rattle of a paper, pop open of a cork, and inevitably, the gentle murmurings of CNN.
“我还没结束今晚，”我大喊。“我还没结束。你甚至不需要跟我说话。我们甚至不需要再见面。但我想要那杯卡布奇诺。而且我想要它，呃，奶泡多多的！”但没有回应。片刻之后，在双层玻璃窗后面遥远的地方，我听到了——报纸的翻动声，瓶塞弹开的声音，以及不可避免的，CNN温柔的低语声。
Writer Sandra Tsing Loh. Her one-woman show, Aliens in America , runs at the Tiffany Theatre in Los Angeles through October.
作家桑德拉·清·洛。她的独角戏《美国的异类》在洛杉矶的蒂芙尼剧院上演至十月。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Starlee Kine, and Sylvia Lemus.
好了，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我制作，苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、蓝色雪维尼（Blue Chevigny）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和顾问萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、斯塔利·基恩（Starlee Kine）和西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Today we say a temporary goodbye to Sylvia Lemus, who talked her way into a position here not long after she first appeared on our program in January of 1998 on her 18th birthday, talking about her Mexican mother's expectations of her and her expectations of herself. She's now off to college to pursue the life that she talked about pursuing back then. We wish her the best. We send her off with love. We expect to hear from her soon on these airwaves.
今天我们暂时告别西尔维娅·莱姆斯，她在1998年1月18岁生日时首次出现在我们的节目中，谈论她墨西哥母亲对她的期望以及她对自己的期望，不久后她就通过谈话为自己争取到了这里的职位。她现在要去上大学，追求她当初谈论的生活。我们祝她一切顺利。我们带着爱送走她。我们期待很快在这些广播频道上听到她的消息。
If you would like to buy a cassette of this program, or that one, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. You know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the Internet, www.thisamericanlife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
如果你想购买本节目的录音带，或者那一期的，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。你知道，你可以在互联网上免费收听我们的大部分节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。感谢管理网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who may have sidled up to you on a school bus years ago and said--
WBEZ的管理由托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他多年前可能曾在校车上蹭到你身边说——
Groundhog? My mama don't eat it, but my daddy do.
土拨鼠？我妈不吃，但我爸吃。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
It's good with gravy.
配上肉汁很好吃。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。